they banking it better be ignorant the
large earthquake in Pakistan in 2013 was
the first time I heard about a big
earthquake I was so shocked by the
number of people's affection and I just
really wanted to help
I started app development when I was 17
which was before I studied at University
I realized my skill of developing apps
would really help so I decided to make
my earthquake alerts which distribute
information about an earthquake much
faster than any other source every
second counts when it comes to an
earthquake son said that they have to
save their lives and they've been able
to get in touch with family members
quickly it's amazing that you really can
build something to help a large number
of people from anywhere in the world
from a city or from a very rural place
like this
grinev Nigeria my friends on I found you
preparing for exams to be poor in
another very efficient so I decided to
get an app that help student prepare for
exams in a fraud and personalized wait
promote is different from the
traditional study methods is a gamified
way of learning and also you get
personalized lessons that are tailored
to individual students using purpose I
clean a game made things far easier for
me I did well in the exams and I go 264
that's a pretty high school I feel
really good fitting the products that
people use every day and it's helpful to
them currently we've talked over 120,000
students across Africa we couldn't have
done this without the three chopped down
I grew up in a loving and supportive
household that sometimes had trouble
putting food on the table so we've
always been aware of thinking about how
to set a budget and how to really make
things stretch there are 42 million
Americans who are on food stamps right
now and most of them have smartphones
and use the internet our app fresh EBT
helps people who receive food stamp
benefits in the United States manage
their balance seemed to become more
financially healthy it also helps people
find grocery recipes and new jobs it
means a lot to us as a team that we are
actually meeting real user needs through
the app
and that's one of the things that's most
rewarding about the work that we do is
we get to see the daily impact of
building a product that really meets the
needs of those who are really seeking
help for is an app that help you sir to
stay focused and what's more important
in their life people would put down
their phones for a while and wait for
the tree to grow down each virtual tree
in the forest app represent focus time
for the user after the app was released
we can some user feedback about if they
can turn real trees in the app let's
when we found the trees from future
[Music]
Chris from future is a nonprofit
organization named le planetary Sounders
they also help local farmers to plan
even type of crops so that they can feed
their families better and have a better
lives we've came to Kenya today for the
first time to visit restore future and
the farmers and farms
this one we call it poetry it's amazing
that a simple app can achieve such
things and being positive impact to
society
thank you all for our users
[Music]
you